it started out very scary I can tell you
that mid-february I was up by about 8
percent year-over-year which is some
nice sort of steady growth and then
whenever the big sort of speeches and
announcements started coming out say
late February or early March on kovat 19
by the end of March I was down 25
percent for the year and I was really
really very scared at that moment and
then April came along and it was very
odd because everyone is locked inside of
their homes and they need audio
equipment and all of a sudden we're
doubling or more our business hey I'm
Dave Rubin and it's Small Business Week
here on the Rubin report joining me
today is Warren dent owner of Zen Pro
audio from Orangeburg South Carolina
Warren welcome to the show good to see
you Dave so I thought you would be the
perfect guy to kick small business week
off because you're the only person this
week in the interviews that I'm gonna be
doing that I actually know so I want to
give you major props first because you
you were a patron you were a viewer of
the Rubin report many years ago when we
were on patreon we got to know each
other a little bit on video chats and
when I built this home studio you said
hey you know I've got an audio company
and Dave I want to hook you up and you
donated gave I don't know what word you
want to use all of our audio stuff so
all of our sound panels people can see
your silent panels behind you you gave
us enough for T sound panels you you
wrote out a great grid for us my
microphone my IFB you donated all that
and your time you've been here and
pointed out some things we could switch
around so number one Thank You Warren
Dent I don't know that I've done that
publicly before I've done it privately
many times you're very welcome and I'm
still very happy to have done that I
think it's just wonderful and I love
what you're doing all right well let's
talk about you a little bit what got you
into creating your companies and
Pro audio did you always want to be a
small businessperson and really what I
want to do for these 10 minutes is learn
about not only your business but but
what's going on because of co vid
because of just the general tumult in
the world right now how's business been
for you and and how can we help you the
people that are watching this yeah so
we're a pro audio online company only so
we don't have a storefront so it's
strictly e-commerce so we sell a lot of
things like microphones and recording
interfaces and things for home studios
podcasters could find a fair amount of
items that would work out well for them
here also as far as my history goes I
grew up with my grandfather owning
multiple businesses as well as my
grandmother in a small town my dad even
before he became disabled my dad was
also a small business owner so yeah I
think it was the thing that I always
knew in the back of my mind that I could
try years ago I started a partnership
company with somebody else and that
didn't work out really for either of us
so I left to start sin Pro at the very
beginning of 2009 and so I've been doing
this we're on our 11th year now we are
still a two man company I own the
company and there's a full-time employee
here as well and so we're known for some
kind of quirky things like we do some
modifications and repairs on certain
items that other dealers don't touch and
it helps us to stand out against the big
box shifter stores by the way I know
that you're a two-man operation but you
also how many kids do you have my friend
just a just eight and I believe they're
all homeschooled am i making that up
every one of them I killed reverse it
foot inside of a public school building
so we very much believe in in
homeschooling so you may only have one
other employee with you but you're
running quite an operation over there in
in South Carolina so business for you I
know because you know people are
podcasting tons of people are doing
stuff from home business for you for the
last couple months has been pretty good
but one of the things that I saw in the
notes that my guys gave me is that it's
sort of erratic just because of the way
the the economy has been right yes it's
started out very scary I can tell you
that mid-february I was up by about 8
percent year-over-year which is some
nice sort of steady growth and then
whenever the big sort of speeches and
announcements started coming out say
late February or early March on kovat 19
by the end of March I was down 25
percent for the year and I was really
really very scared at that moment and
then April came along and it was very
odd because everyone is locked inside of
their homes and they need audio
equipment and all of a sudden we're
doubling or more our business and so
from April on things have actually been
very good I don't know how long it will
last you know I I'm not a gambling guy
at all but that was very interesting I
went for really scared I mean 10 people
rely on me for their livelihood for
their food for their shelter for
everything and so boy I was really just
torn up over it and then when April hit
I was like oh my gosh I guess for now
we're gonna be okay so yes business
right now is actually quite good being
an e-commerce only and selling items
that people really need there's one
thing that I found funny is that the Joe
Rogan Mike which is a model from sure
that Mike we always sell a fair amount
of that microphone when everybody got
locked inside of their house that Mike
flew off the shelf and went on a
nationwide backorder instantly so the
good and probably the bad news is
everybody's probably starting their new
podcast cuz they're locked inside of
their house because if we need anything
if we need anything right now it's it's
more add more podcast there definitely
aren't enough podcast can you kind of
talk about just generally your your
philosophy related to business like as
far as how do you decide how much stuff
to order how much debt to accrue or not
to accrue how to stay slim and trim as I
said it's just as you said it's just you
and one other guy over there correct
so I mean I make all those decisions
the owner I will tell you that one of
the things that has been key is trying
to get in front of interruptions to the
supply chain so I've even reached out to
some suppliers especially in the early
weeks and I said look guys tell me what
you have and you can start to see the
gaps that we're coming up and I would
just go ahead and overload so something
that I might stock three or four I might
order twenty or thirty and then by the
time they would get here including the
Joe Rogan Mike all of that stuff would
ship right out the door
so it has changed the way that I have to
look at the market from a stocking
standpoint on certain items that are
extremely popular yeah what else is
going on business-wise do you think like
as as small business owners what what
are you guys seeing maybe besides the
supply chain although I guess that is a
huge amount of it that maybe just the
average person that you know works for a
company but isn't the owner of business
isn't gonna see wow I mean in my small
town I mean there's men's you know some
restaurants that have just gone ahead
and left I've watched them do that I
feel like brick-and-mortar would be the
real question here which luckily I'm not
subject to that we all know that
brick-and-mortar in certain industries
has been very very difficult for people
that's the part that I fear the most the
US ecommerce guys I've been ecommerce
since day one of this business and so
watching those brick and mortars really
struggle I've been out to a few it's
really heartbreaking to see such a thing
because they don't have a good online
presence and their own governments are
obviously locking them out of these
buildings and telling them that it's for
their own good so that that's the part I
think is gonna be super bad when you see
a store like Best Buy or some of the big
box stores that sell some of the types
of stuff that you sell does it seem like
a dinosaur at this point just the other
day I was returning a computer to Best
Buy that I bought in the middle middle
of lockdown I was trying to return it I
had to wait online for about an hour you
can't go into the store if you want to
buy something else you have to order in
advance like the whole thing seems kind
of crazy where you can find a guy in
South Carolina Zen Pro Audio calm and
you can get all that stuff
I'm sure you got a pretty decent return
policy if it doesn't work out and that
these big box stores it almost seems
like it's just gonna be a total relic of
the past it does cut out that step so in
other words we actually don't do a lot
of returns here we're pretty good at
qualifying customers for their needs but
I will say that it does cut out that
part of the process so if somebody wants
to return something to us they probably
need to go to the UPS Store or FedEx or
something but as far as Best Buy you
specifically mention them I will
personally say the reason that I like
Best Buy's because if I want to buy a TV
I can build look at it and walk out the
store with it I think there's value in
that I needed a piece of furniture for
my daughter a few weeks ago and I
realized that Best Buy was doing things
by appointment only I hate to say it I
just went ahead and bought what I needed
somewhere else because that's a pain and
I also live about 40 miles from the
store and there was it was difficult to
go oh hey I'm gonna be there at this
particular time and can you let me in I
really didn't like that and I so I don't
blame Best Buy for that as much as I
blame authorities for telling them that
they have to do certain things and then
you and I both know it's the lawyers at
the end of the day that are affecting
business they are telling businesses
like Best Buy you have got to do these
certain things because if one kovat case
is traced back to a guy checking out a
TV in your store there's gonna be a
class-action suit or something like that
so I do believe that is part of what's
going on well we have done some of our
libertarian beliefs over drinks so we'll
have to leave that to the next time I
see you in person
I just wanna clarify your yeah I just
want to clarify you're misremembering I
don't drink but that's okay well we hug
it no no no the last time we hung I'd
believe you hard though it was at a bar
I think you had a club soda or something
somebody had a drink
you I think you bought me a coke anyway
I bought you a coke Jordan Peterson was
there I won't say what he drank was a
good time anyway listen pimp yourself
out for the good people oh and I should
mention that in the midst of all of this
craziness and again we did not know each
other a couple years ago and yet you
donated all this stuff and I'm super
appreciate of it but you've also become
a
investor in locals dot-com because you
believe in the mission so that's another
sort of small business type operation in
the startup world but pimp out Zen Pro
audio for the people better podcasting
or or want to hear their video games
better or whatever else it might be I'm
sure we ship worldwide we've got a quite
a selection of things things that are in
stock a lot of things we're waiting on
right now but yeah check us out at Zen /
audio.com
again we're it were an owner operated
business a two-man operation we do offer
some customized mods and some other
things like that to try to separate
ourselves from the others free ship on
most orders like anyone else oh sure
it'd be great if people wanted to check
us out all right thank you my friend Zen
pro audio.com if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell